-It's time to play a game
of deception
called "True Confessions."
♪♪
Wow.
My first opponent
is an amazing actor
whose new animated series,
"The Great North,"
airs Sundays at 8:30 p.m.
on FOX.
Please welcome Nick Offerman.
Nick, it is great to see you.
-Thank you, Jimmy.
Good to see you.
-Nick and I will be facing off
against a talented model
who just launched a brand-new
YouTube channel today.
Please welcome Hailey Bieber.
Oh!
Hailey, welcome, welcome,
welcome.
I'm happy you guys are here.
Here's how this works.
Each of us have two envelopes
containing confessions.
One is true, the other is a lie.
Once you read your confession,
the other players
will interrogate you,
and then they have to come to
a unanimous decision --
is it the truth or a lie?
Nick, you will go first.
Hailey, which envelope
should he open,
number one or number two?
-Number two.
-Yeah, I agree.
-Yep.
-In a Tokyo --
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Who wrote these?
In a Tokyo hotel lobby,
I once offered my services
to a middle-aged businessman
as a prostitute.
-[ Chuckles ]
What?
Wait, no.
What -- What --
Alright, what year was this?
-1991.
-And why were you in Tokyo?
-I was touring a Kabuki
theater show around Japan.
-Yeah. And you were in
the Kabuki theater?
-I was. I was cast as...
soldier number three.
-[ Laughs ]
It's so outlandish that I feel
like it might be true.
-There was a language situation
that maybe created
a bit of a snafu.
-Ah. [ Laughs ]
-I was going to say
there's no way that's true,
but I don't know.
I think honestly
that now makes me think
that it actually did happen.
Hailey, what do you think?
-That's -- What I was saying
before is
it sounds so outlandish
that perhaps it's true.
♪♪
-You are correct.
That actually did occur.
[ Ding ]
-Yes!
-[ Laughs ]
What happened?
Wait. What did you think
you were saying?
-Yeah, what was going on here?
-My two friends and I
were having breakfast
in this hotel lobby,
and they were also
in the show.
And this older gentleman
came over,
and he was very interested
to meet us.
And we were trying to
make conversation,
and he was offering us
cigarettes.
And we were smokers then,
so we took them.
And we kept saying
we're in the Kabuki show,
and his eyes would light up.
And so what happened was...
-[ Laughs ] What?
-...Kabuki is the theater style,
but it is also slang
for "prostitutes."
-Oh, wow!
-So we were saying to this guy,
"We're in a theater show,"
and what he was hearing is,
"Hello.
We're American hookers.
[ Laughter ]
-It is now -- It is my turn.
Which envelope should I open?
Number one, number two?
Do you care?
-I'll go number one.
-Is that what you propositioned
to the guy?
[ Laughter ]
Here we go.
One time, I accidentally dined
and dashed with Alec Baldwin
because we each thought
the other person paid the bill.
You know him.
Questions?
-Doesn't seem impossible to me.
But here's what
I want to know --
Where were you dining?
-It was Pierre's,
which is a French bistro
in East Hampton.
-Oh, you're good.
That's a good detail.
-So, Hailey, you know this turf,
I presume.
-Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
I feel like I should have
a sixth sense
because this is someone
I'm related to.
Um...hmm.
I'm going to say
that I think
that that's probably true.
-I'm going to say it's true.
-It's false.
-[ Gasps ]
-What?!
-That's the best acting
I've ever done in my life!
We would nev--
I've been to dinner with Alec,
but, no,
we never dined and dashed
at Pierre's.
I made the whole thing up.
-You said it was an accident!
-I made the whole thing up!
-Wow, you are diabolical, Jimmy.
-Never, ever, ever happened.
Yes!
That's the greatest acting.
I should get back into movies.
-I'm impressed. I'm impressed.
-Thank you.
Hailey, it is now your turn.
Nick, which envelope
should she open --
number one or number two?
-I will go with number two,
please.
-Yep.
-Number two, okay.
[ Sighs ]
Number two says...
one time,
I got lost on a jet ski
and was chased
by a pack of wild dogs.
♪♪
-Okay.
-Phew.
-I know. That's a thinker.
It's a brain bender
only because --
I'm just not seeing
the wild dogs
on the water chasing you.
And they have to be
running pretty fast
to be chasing you on a jet ski,
wouldn't you say, Nick?
-Well, unless --
are "The Wild Dogs"
the name of a marauding gang...
-[ Laughs ] Like a jet ski gang?
-...in the Hampton area,
perhaps?
[ Laughter ]
-The Wild Dogs. Yeah,
they're a famous jet ski gang.
I've heard of these.
They're like a lake gang.
-No, we're talking
real, live wild dogs.
-Was it night or day?
-What are you talking --
-It was daytime.
-You can't jet ski at nighttime.
-Jet skiing at night
sounds dangerous.
-Yeah.
-I'm not a big
jet ski enthusiast.
I apologize.
You --
Did you survive the encounter?
-[ Laughs ]
Obviously.
Alright. Wait a second.
-Well, I'm here.
-Yes, you're here.
Well, how did you get to land?
I'm assuming they chased you
around the beach.
-We were actually doing
a little boat excursion,
and we had taken the jet skis
off the boat...
-Okay. Alright. Here we go.
-...to explore,
and we ended up just barely
making it back
after a few of the jet skis
had died.
-Yep. This is --
You know why this is true?
Nick?
Because I was a model myself,
and when you are successful,
you do -- you party.
-Okay. Jimmy,
did I hear correctly?
Are you attempting to tell me
what models do?
[ Laughter ]
As though I'm not a very --
-No, no, no, no, no, no,
I would never say that.
That is not -- Dude, no no.
I would never --
Sorry to insult you.
Dude, I've known you
for a long time. So --
-I'm -- Listen, I mean, I guess
I'm either gullible
or you guys are very talented,
because I'm also leaning towards
believing this story.
And also, I'm just going to text
my business manager real quick
because I'm going to invent
a jet ski with a headlight
and --
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
That's not the point
of all of this!
-Get the [bleep]
-Chased by wild dogs
on a jet ski,
which is, honestly,
that is an insane story.
I'm going to say it sounds
so bizarre that it's true.
-I agree. We say true.
-You guys are correct.
[ Laughing ]
That is a true story.
-My thanks to Nick Offerman,
Hailey Bieber.
That was "True Confessions."